No, lay down, lay down I just brought this over as an example
Hi, Bubba. Oh no no. You- You relax I brought them to you you want your little baby?
Do you want your baby, oh there you go. Hey Bubba! Hey Bubba? How's it going? No, you sleep.
You snores away, you sleepy. I'll sleep with you.
Is that good? I haven't done a good old floor vlog in a while. Hey paint me like one of your French YouTubers.
Excuse me Chica-- Excuse me. Excuse me! I know the fans love you more, but this is not necessary.
Hey guys!
How's it going? Bet you wondered where I've been.
*The demon named septiplier screaming from the deep depths of hell trying to escape*
So this past week I have been absent.
It hasn't- It's been a while since I've missed one day let alone a WHOLE week mysteriously.
And I explained it in a vlog while I was over at the location where we were filming at,
Uh, but there was no internet there. And and that's not lie, like later today
I'm going to upload like five videos because I recorded them ahead of time, and I meant to upload them
But when we were there, I was like for some reason I didn't just upload them here. I was like "Oh I'll upload there
I don't care if it takes overnight." Even that video that
I showed you like I uploaded that from my phone because I was standing on that balcony and just holding my phone over the edge of uh-
THE ABYSS
Oops, I'm sorry puppy
This is her baby because it still has its face.
Chica is a vicious beast that tears the face off of every-- I thought this adorable puppy
would survive the onslaught, but, oh, no. I'm just a lil bit
DECAPITATED
So this past week I've been filming with a bunch of my friends out in the boonies as I call them.
But we were filming at this castle for this a multi-part video that
We're gonna release soon, and I would love to tell you all about it!
I really would- The rest of the team would kill me if I did, but I would want to tell you about it.
And that's not just me reverse psychology getting you to like be hyped about it like I really want to tell you about it.
Oh- Puppy. Puppy.
Well, but trust me when I say it's one of those things that the less you know about it now the better it will be
For you when you actually see it. Its a huge project. We've never done anything this big or ambitious. It's not a youtube red series
It's not a movie
It's just a project that we were very
passionate about and we wanted to do the best we could at and we did like this past week has been amazing and
Admittedly this past week has been not good for videos on this channel. I know I
Broke some promises there haha- Well, I mean what can I do- what can you do about that?
Ah well, what can you do? Not that I was dismissing the the aspect of promises or keeping promises, but this past week has been like
Fulfilling for me and in a way that I haven't seen like like me filming a project be fulfilling in a while
Number one because it was something that we all
Were very very passionate about it's something that we all like really really loved- What're you looking for bub? What you looking for? MOnkey?
It was something that we were all supremely passionate about and it was something that *squeak* really really- ooh
It was something that really really gave me more insight on myself, and that's what weird thing to say especially considering
I'm 28 years old now like I'm a full-fledged adult I've been paying taxes for years now
I have an accountant like I am an adult
I'm about as adult as it comes, and I know you guys are currently typing up your examples of how I'm not an adult
I'm a meme chugging idiot
But that's besides the point the point of the matter is I learned more about myself even though I've been in this body *starts giggling* for a while
That didn't make any sense, but then again nothing
I say does but it's funny because
Everything I do
is a reflection of who I am right like these videos that I make they're a reflection of who I am because I'm honest and
Even though that honesty is never a lie- that doesn't mean that
I can't change over time I used to be caught up in this vicious cycle of "oh, man,
I could have been so good at this if I had started then" or "if I- if I'd've been doing this instead of that"
And and and that's why I make like such sweeping statements like promises like I'll never miss an upload date and and admittedly
The day after I posted that video, I was like, "Oh, I dug myself a hole now,
how am I gonna get out of this one? Well, you can't you're just an idiot, you gotta live with it."
but what but the
Reason I said that is because I was mad at myself and the reason I was mad at myself was because I was getting lazy
Like it really was and that's what caught me. That's what made me go like uh, what are you doing? Oh no.
and then like as like penance for myself I
Created this schedule that I never wanted to break and admittedly I wasn't gonna break it if the internet wasn't there. Today,
I am gonna upload just a whole bunch of videos you guys are gonna see him today
I've got a ton of "West of Loathing" in the- in the pocket that I'll be spreading out throughout the day
it's like it was a kick in the ass and
Sometimes you just need a kick in the ass even if you're kicking your own ass
Sometimes you just need to be kicked in the ass
And that's where that's where I can come across as an asshole sometimes
like I'm
I care a lot about what we do here and I care a lot about this community that we've built so while at the same time I
Like to kick in the ass for what it did
For me work ethic wise I didn't like the kick in the ass because it caused me to
Post videos at any cost, you know what I mean? And that means that I'll post a video that
I'm not too happy with and that's like my number one rule.
I don't want to make videos that I'm not happy with because everything I do I pour my heart and soul into and
I want that to be shown like the honesty of who I am is
apparent to everybody that watches this because I
Am just me and I'll only ever be me and so the only way that I can ever be better
Is by being true to myself and yes, I will change
But in the long run that change will hopefully be for the better because you guys are there to correct- pfft me
On this endeavor like does that make any sense
I know that's a lot of bullshit words and whatnot but it's what I was realizing this weekend like I love making videos
I love these big projects. I love pushing myself to do great things while at the same time
Trying to keep up this rigorous schedule
It's a challenge
And it's a balance and it's something that's really fun because while at the same time, I love doing these videos
I also love doing odd
Other projects, like I've been falling in love with music
Lately like I've been listening to so much Ed Sheeran, a little bit of James Arthur, like Harry Styles
I love his new song "Sign of the times" like I've found myself falling into music and
it's something that I want to I want to dedicate my time to
But then again, there's just not enough time today to do everything so I just find myself having to hMM spread myself pretty thin
That's it that like that's it. That's the long the short of it. There is no end goal here. There is no business
I'm building. There's no nothing else
There's no long term plan
Because the video- the videos that I make in this channel is the most accurate reflection of my life. I could possibly make and
The fact that you guys are along for the journey is just the biggest honor
I could ever hope for, and this community that we've built and the causes that we rally for are just
Like it's just the most delightful thing that I could ever hope for- and I know delightful's not the word to use for that
But I don't care like that's a description that I can make for it whenever I see
The fact that we rally around these things and you guys are there for me for these videos
And- and- and not to kiss your ass about it, but I like - listen, I really do I
really do love you guys. I
do and I know it's such a mean to say that about your fan base, and I know everyone's like oh, no
I love my fans I lOVE
My fans, I would do anything for my fans, and I know it's such a joke to say that at this point
But God just thank you (you're welcome Mark ^-^)
Like honestly, thank you like thank you a million times the fact that I'm able to do this and projects like this, you know
They're like they *struggles with wording* They're so time
intensive and they take so many resources and it costs a lot of money
And I don't care like I don't care like I don't care about any of that like I just care about
Making the best things that I can make because I owe it to you guys
I owe it to you guys to push myself and not that I'm ever gonna hurt myself for your benefit like
(angry fire alarm)
(startled Markimoo)
They called me on my bullshit!
Oh no!
Ah that's over- (smooch)
I'd like to think that the thing you guys stick around for is the fact that I'm-
I have no idea what I'm doing and that means that I could do anything at any moment, and I think that's cool
But change is good sometimes
Sometimes it's shit
But sometimes is good. You know it's worth the risk. You can't stay stagnant forever if things stay the same forever
We'd never go anywhere, right so so the good or the bad, I will keep changing and I'll keep thanking you guys so also
we're doing a charity campaign this uh this week this month is for the Joyful Heart Foundation and
for this
Particular charity I am not going to be doing a charity livestream, and that's not out of laziness
I do have time. I could do one tomorrow
I could have done one last weekend, and I have really thought about it
but the reason why I
Can't do a charity livestream for this cause is not because I don't want to support it as much as anything else
I've ever done. It's because
the Joyful Heart foundation is for victims of sexual assault I am not the right person to be a
champion for that cause I have never
experienced sexual assault and in a livestream setting where usually I talk about
you know stories about it, I talk about- I talk to people to share their stories about it and
The fact of the matter is there are people that are currently going through the healing process of dealing with these
sexual assaults
And it would almost be detrimental to certain people's healing process to bring that up and make people relive it
so for this one, I will only say
There is Merch down in the description
There is a till to five page for donations for the Joyful heart foundation the merch proceeds go to the charity
I don't make any money off of it the donations. Go directly to the charity. I don't take any of it
I'm gonna donate myself and
Please just help out this great cause and- and- and in addition to that currently there's flooding in Houston
Texas from Hurricane Henry (Mark it's Harvey, Hurricane Harvey not Henry) like I'll also put a link in the description for
like various foundations that will help out in the aid and relief efforts for
Helping the victims of the flooding and helping like search parties to do that
So please if you can donate to either those causes take your pick
they're both great efforts, and you know just my heart goes out to everybody that's been affected by it and
Like we did a show in Houston
Like we were there like we were we were just there. I've only ever seen it once and it was during that show and
Like I just can't imagine that just - all of that, just being flooded away
It's it's heartbreaking and again
I'm like I'm not the right
spokesperson to say about it because I didn't live in Houston so all I can do it is ask you guys to help out and
Help out wherever you can even if you're nearby maybe even a volunteer effort would be good so yeah, I
Think that's about the long this short of all I wanted to talk about today
So thank you everybody so much for watching there will be a ton of videos coming up this week
And I'm going to Pax at the end of this week, so if you're going there, I'll see you there
and it should be a fun time like there's exciting videos coming and
There's not exciting videos coming, and then there's really mediocre videos coming, and then there's gonna be highs and lows to everything
But thanks for sticking with me
It means the world and it means you will do BP, right butch. Are you sleeping?
Thanks again, and as always. I will see you in the next video bye-bye